hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my brand new recording
room it's an entire room dedicated just
to recording these videos that you're
seeing now and I've never had this
before if you know me you know that my
life is in utter shambles and I live
like a slob
but other than that I also have always
had my recording setup next to my bed
which is something that I have now
officially changed and I have an entire
room dedicated to just this [ __ ]
here all this acid tree that you've seen
is gonna be amplified a whole lot and
I'm not cramped in a corner next to my
bed which is a welcome change to be
honest but this is also why yesterday's
videos were all kinds of cur [ __ ] in
that they weren't there until way late
at night and then it was way too late so
if you also know me you know that I do
not plan good and I do not account for
things such as untangling the horrifying
mess of cables that is my recording
setup and moving that to another roof
like Charlotte's Web if she was on LSD
and already dead spoiler sorry so the
room is almost ready
it's not quite done there's still some
more acoustic foam to be put up on the
other side and the ceiling you may get a
little bit of echo but for right now
it's a welcome change the new foam it's
not the same that it was before it's
delightful and I love it it's much
better quality too much more it's this
it's foam so I'm really looking forward
to making a new generation of videos
from this room they're gonna be exactly
the same and exactly as bad but they're
going to be in this place now that looks
better yeah so thank you everybody so
much for being patient and I apologize
again for the delays let's get back to
the games though right now okay so the
first game that we're going to be
playing is called play with me I'm
pretty sure you want to play well you
don't know me very well because I don't
know what I want but I'm sure it's not
to be eaten by a horrifying clown which
is in this game but never look at me in
the eye
why will I die if I look in your eye
will you cry if I look in your eye will
you throw a pie if I look in your eye
will you this better not be a lie about
looking in your eye I bet he has the
power to fly if I look in his eye
I whatever let's go except if you want
to die oh I already made that rhyme so
you're a sack of [ __ ] and I'm a winner
find the four candles to solve the
puzzle then reach the key that'll set
you free boy you're sure do like rhymes
like I'm a little more but we'll see
about that Oh
so this game is about um a clown oh okay
I came over
oh I can't move I just can't move
forward well what the hell Oh
hi I'm still figuring out the controls
here can you give me a second I think
maybe I need the gamepad for this just
don't kill me I'll be right back there
there we go I can't look though well I
gotta use a combination of like I gotta
use a combination of the gamepad and the
mouse
this is wunderbar how do I collect it
click on it yeah it's like dungeon
nightmares controls door squeak okay
thank you for being oh I saw something
down there am i what is that okay I
don't think that's an eye but hi how you
doing what are you doing over there
should I follow okay yeah [ __ ] off hey
[ __ ] up whoa I'm dead
holy [ __ ] I'm not ready for this I got I
got two hands on different things over
here maybe it was like that oh it was
like that it was the directional arrows
damn it I'm an idiot
I was using WASD when I should have been
using the arrow keys oh boy oh hi
grandma Hayden you good oh you're not
there there sure are you okay
[ __ ] oh I'm alive oh okay oh [ __ ] off
man
this guy's doesn't stop jeezum 'he's hey
[ __ ] yeah you're like the most active
monster I've ever seen oh my god
what do we do I don't know what I do I
can't run oh did I die
I probably died I don't know
what the [ __ ] just happened to me I
having a goddamn clue what the hell can
I run I don't even think I can run under
does any way to run here that's a door
that you look like a door
oh man hello that's ominous and scary oh
wait I saw like smoke does that mean
that he's gonna appear there okay what
was that up there
hey hey no hey no hmm okay I don't know
if these are randomly generated location
but the definitely wasn't any more up
here before but maybe they'll be now in
grandma's really looking at my grandma
okay so that's scripted hmm this guy's a
sack of [ __ ] hi okay so we know about
those that means he's probably an
appearance room to bug me get that get
that get back at that okay get out of
here whew oh he's over in that room okay
that's good don't look him in the eye
don't look him in the eye oh she is
quiet oh oh oh okay oh that's lovely man
this game is this game hey [ __ ] oh don't
do that
this game is super active and this is a
whole drum line that's ready to dick
with me
it is oh good okay okay okay I'm okay
I'm okay I'm okay where am i where am i
where am i I don't know where I am oh I
don't know why oh my god this sack of
[ __ ] oh well alright then that's a loud
not open to bull sound alright where
else do I go is there like another way
down is there a basement you'd assume in
these horror houses mmm okay so dark I
can't see exactly where everything is
okay so I've already done this so hello
yeah I know okay so I went down that way
right can I go out damn it of course I
can't go well well I kind of sped
through here but I already got the
candle in there I don't know how many
candles there are because the numbers on
the candles went up to 20 and I don't
know why so there must be another one
like an attic there's either an attic or
a basement because indeed these horror
games are always is okay so there must
have been something in these rooms that
I missed
hey that's new that the key to the front
door
mmm can I get out oh I didn't sound good
well [ __ ]
well dick making me good little long way
around
don't take with me don't dick with me
you're not dick with me I'm almost out
of here [ __ ] off I'm out of here
I'm out of here I'm assuming this is
Akitas you to the front door it is not
to the front door then it's definitely
to the other door that was locked before
but I think I'm okay okay mom did it
baby
dog hmm well is that the eye is it the
eye the eye
whoa-oh okay that's the end of it that's
how it's supposed to end you can never
escape wow I've never seen a horror game
throw so many things at you in such a
short amount of time that was
astonishing I mean I think it was one of
those games that had to hit you fast or
else you know the scares would have
become dull over time but still that was
pretty good so either way that's the end
of that game Oh took two months to make
damn it was well made like I'm not
saying that like or just took two months
Jesus no it was actually pretty good I
like this a lot I don't know about the
longevity of it and how much it could be
expanded into another game but for what
it was it was very good so thank you
everybody so much for watching and thank
you for being patient while I get my new
recording setup all up and running so we
will see some new stuff coming out of
here very soon thanks again everybody
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
Megan whoo
Velma has shaken spats